les détonations s'enchaînent
manifestants palestiniens et police
israélienne se provoque
après les heurts de la veille reconnu
comme les pires troubles que la ville
sainte est connue depuis plusieurs
années les palestiniens continuent de
dénoncer des actes qu'il qualifie de
provocant et racistes de la part de
l'état hébreu
alors que la cour suprême d'israël doit
se prononcer demain quant à l'expulsion
ou non de familles palestiniennes qui
livrait sur des terres appartenant aux
juifs dans jérusalem est
les pèlerins musulmans se plaignent
d'avoir été empêché par la police
israélienne d'aller prier sur la grande
esplanade ces tensions à jérusalem est
ont déclenché d'importantes vagues de
violences dans toute la cisjordanie
occupée dans la bande de gaza contrôlée
depuis 2010 cette part le hamas les
palestiniens protestent violemment son
soutien à ces familles menacées
d'expulsion et aux musulmans bloqués par
la police
c'est un message d'abord pour tous ceux
qui dans la ville inébranlable de
jérusalem résiste à l'occupation et à
ses politiques racistes et sanglante
tout votre peuple en cisjordanie dans la
bande de gaza et de la diaspora est
derrière vous il est sorti aujourd'hui
pour vous soutenir dans cette situation
et maintenir une posture de fermeté et
de défis à cheikh jarrah et à la mosquée
al aqsa dans la bande de gaza nous
disons à ceux de notre peuple à sheikh
jarrah que si dieu le veut gaza est
derrière vous tout comme vous avait
scandé pour gaza cette fois gaz a
entendu l'appel est sorti en disant que
nous sommes avec notre peuple à
jérusalem et en cisjordanie
nous disons révolutionnaire dans les
cour de la mosquée al aqsa de passer la
bénédiction de dieu et de la résistance
palestinienne à gaza sur l'alliance
l'ampleur des violences la nuit dernière
a poussé le kart est pour le proche
orient a sonné l'alarmé dans un
communiqué publié dans la nuit de samedi
à dimanche sur le site du ministère
russe des affaires étrangères
l'onu l'union européenne les états unis
et la russie ont exprimé leurs
inquiétudes concernant la situation dans
le pays
nous appelons les autorités israéliennes
à faire preuve de retenue et à éviter
des mesures qui pourraient entraîner une
escalade de la situation durant cette
période deux jours saints musulmans avec
les événements tragiques qui se
déroulent depuis plusieurs semaines
l'état hébreu est en train de se mettre
à dos une grande partie du moyen-orient
tandis que le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan a accusé israël d'être un
état terroriste
hier la jordanie gardienne des lieux
saints musulmans de jérusalem est et qui
a signé la paix il ya près de 30 ans
avec israël a dénoncé je cite une
agression sauvage contre les
palestiniens